con retos complejos por afrontar inicia
la asamblea general de la ONU la guerra
en Ucrania la inflación mundial que ha
provocado la invasión y la inestabilidad
económica tras la pandemia marcarán
parte de la agenda internacional
excelencias nos reunimos en un momento
de Gran peligro para nuestro mundo
conflictos y catástrofes climáticas
desconfianza y división pobreza
desigualdad y discriminación
el secretario general de la ONU
aprovechó para hacer un llamado a
deponer las armas y buscar una salida
pacífica a las confrontaciones
por encima de todo no puede haber un
futuro sostenible sin paz abrazando la
paz y la tolerancia y lo que es más
importante viviendo estos valores cada
día podemos dar un paso más hacia el
mundo sostenible igualitario y justo que
toda persona merece Este martes comienza
el debate general con los discursos de
los líderes mundiales que volverán a la
presencialidad luego de que la página de
Kobe 19 y era una tregua el primer
discurso será dado por Brasil como
extradición para luego dar paso al país
anfitrión Estados Unidos pero este año
el presidente joeyden quien estuvo en el
sepelio de la Reina Isabel segunda
pronunciará sus palabras el miércoles
Palestina que no es miembro de la ONU al
igual que el Vaticano y la Unión Europea
serán observadores permanentes este año
entre los que se estrenan en su primera
asamblea están tres presidentes
latinoamericanos izquierdistas el
chileno Gabriel borich el colombiano
Gustavo Petro y la hondureña Xiomara
Castro además están los de las potencias
europeas el casillero alemán olafchols y
la primera ministra de Reino Unido Liz
tras los presidentes de Rusia y China
serán los grandes ausentes debido a las
tensiones por la guerra en Ucrania y el
conflicto en Taiwán Aunque Sí asistirá
en sus ministros de relaciones
exteriores